uh welcome to the 32nd kuznets Memorial
lecture organized by economic growth
Center I'm rohini Pandey the director of
the economic growth Center and a
professor and economics Department
I'd also like to thank those who are
joining us online I gather we have a
record number of people who've chosen to
do so today's talk is being broadcast
and also recorded we'll invite
everyone's participation in the Q a but
remind you that by being present here
today you consent to have your comments
recorded and posted publicly
Memorial lecture is an annual talk
focusing on issues in Economic
Development which the growth Center
hosts in honor of Simon kuznets the
Nobel prize-winning Economist who helped
found the center in 1961.
among kuznets many achievements was
coming up with the original found
formulation of gross domestic product or
GDP which he presented in a report to
the U.S Congress in 1937.
GDP was soon widely used to measure
economic development but kuznets himself
called his own measure into question as
early as 1934 he cautioned against a
narrow focus on GDP saying the welfare
of a Nation can scarcely be inferred
from a measurement of national income
in 1962 he added distinctions must be
kept in mind between quantity and
quality of growth between its costs and
returns and between the short and long
term
today we're going to hear from Ileana
about ideas that illuminate this
complicated relationship between the
quantity and quality of growth
iliana's groundbreaking research has
shown that Customs beliefs and other
social norms can disrupt the link
between wealth and well-being and
increase inequality between groups even
as countries get richer her work
highlights the fact that we can't
understand Economic Development without
recognizing the role of informal
norm-based institutions family groups
immigrant communities traditional gender
roles and others
Ileana is the professor of public policy
at Harvard Kennedy School she will also
be the incoming president of the
econometric society in 2024 a society
that Yale has many connections with
in 2020 Ileana received the burger award
which is awarded annually by the
European economic Association to a woman
who has made significant contributions
to the economics profession
personally I've always been a huge
admirer of ileana's work and how
thoughtfully she has worked to improve
our profession I'm delighted that she
has agreed to spend this week with us to
Anchor the kuznes mini conference
tomorrow which has brought many young
leading Scholars to our campus and to
deliver the 32nd cousiness lecture on
changing harmful Norms please join me in
welcoming lyanna
thank you
thank you Rooney and so this is an
incredible honor for me
um so I'm grateful to you to the EGC to
the department for the hospitality these
days also the opportunity to organize
this mini conference tomorrow uh was so
welcome and uh you know it allowed me to
connect with many of the young
researchers that I've interacted with in
my first life in Europe and so you will
see for those of you who are around
tomorrow that there's a lot of
commonality and a lot of bridges that I
hope we can continue creating between
development economists here and in in
the European continent so
um I'd like to you know start
motivating a bit the choice of the topic
for this lecture and why I think it's
important to talk about Norms if we care
about development and as economists we
always emphasize the key role played by
incentives and we tend to think that by
giving material incentives to markets or
through institutions we can affect
individual behavior and so changing the
structure of incentives under is an
underlying principle for many of the
interventions we have including
anti-poverty interventions if you look
at other social sciences and here I
mentioned psychology sociology but in
general the focus there when they
analyze behavior is on
includes many other factors for example
Identity or social influence and Within
These disciplines nor me Norm based
interventions are a lot more common and
in that case the understanding is that
you can change Behavior by shifting
perception of what is normal what is
expected in one's reference group so
there's no reason why these two
approaches should be seen as distinct or
you know mutually exclusive quite the
opposite uh in in my research I've tried
to understand the extent to which they
can complement and reinforce each other
so rohini mentioned uh kuznets and if
you read the motivation for his Nobel
Prize we all associate his contributions
to growth inequality but the motivation
actually mentions his empirically
founded interpretation of growth which
has led to a new and deepen insight into
the economic and social structure and
the process of development so it is
important I think also in the context of
this lecture to underline that the the
importance of social factors has been
there since the origin of our field in
our profession
so uh I'm gonna give you a very quick
um kind of definition of norms borrowing
on from the work of Christina bikiri
who's one of the leading researchers uh
on social norms and uh Christina defines
Norms as shared behavioral rules that
prescribe or prescribe behaviors within
a large class of situations so we can
think of norms as a form of grammar
grammar tells you you know how you
should arrange words sentences what is
acceptable what is not in the way you're
of speaking or writing and Norms instead
of dictating how words are formed and
Order dictate the behavior that you are
expected to engage in particular
situations
now these behaviors are basically
interdependent and so the individual
choice to comply with the norm naturally
depends on the expectations of what
other people uh will do and there's two
types of expectations
um uh one empirical or positive we might
think which is what do you expect other
people to do in a similar situation so
how common is it to choose this Behavior
would a sufficiently large fraction of
my reference group take this action the
other is the normative expectation what
should you do okay what do other expect
that you should do and in this case the
question becomes
is there a sufficiently large fraction
in the community that expects me to
behave in a certain way okay and these
Norms can really play wonderful uh
functions or can become obstacles and be
bad Norms so economists have studied the
benefits of norms in settings where
there are Market imperfections where
some markets are absent institutions are
also you know have limitations when it
comes to enforcement and there's a a lot
of work done on for example the
potential for informal Insurance
networks and or informal credit and
Norms that govern Cooperative Behavior
within this type of transactions which
obviously have the potential of
facilitating uh growth but today we're
gonna Focus On the Dark Side of norms
and of norms that might cause Behavior
to in a way that's inefficient not
conducive to to growth so the same type
of risk sharing that can function very
well to isolate the poor from income
fluctuations can also generate excessive
pressure or excessive solidarity as has
been documented
or there can be Norms that you know
prescribe what occupation you are
expected to engage in for example if you
are a member of a certain caste we'll
talk today about a norm which has to do
with gender and unfortunately in the
area of gender you know there's only an
embarrassment in how many of these
detrimental works you can find well
Dowry we know are you know payments
associated with marriage that impose
very high costs often you know in in the
order of a whole year of income for a
family there's child marriage I'll talk
about female genital cutting
historically there were Norms like food
binding in China
there are norms even to this day for
example that restrict women's Mobility
during mystery all of these are norms
that for us are not so easy to come to
terms with because if we measure the
expected costs and benefit in terms of
productivity they don't seem to really
play a role that would justify their
existence so um having acknowledged this
the question is going to be why are
these Norms uh still there and if we
want to facilitate their disappearance
what can we do as policy makers and what
I want to do today is to take you
through two
sets of uh
um you know results considerations uh
analytical uh work that I've engaged in
one that looks at the evolution of norms
without a specific intervention on
behalf of policy makers and trying to to
understand to what extent we can expect
these Norms to fade away on their own
the second is a more Hands-On approach
where you think about policy and you say
is there a role for information uh
provision can we think that you know
there's some misperception that is
keeping these Norms alive what is the
role played by culture or by identity
and here I will report on some recent
work that I've done with actually some
of the people who are here
in the audience and that sheds light
using
experiments and in both cases I will use
one of these extremely harmful gender
Norms which is female genital cutting
although I think at least for the third
part when we talk about Evolution and
kind of the theoretical analysis of
these transitions I don't think there is
anything that is really necessarily
specific of fgc in what I will say okay
so what is female genital cutting
it is the practice of cutting or
removing part of the extender or
internal female genitalia for no medical
reasons it's an initiation ritual that's
performed on girls between infancy and
age 15 very often it's around you know 8
to 11 years old that girls are cut and
it's again most in most cases performed
not in a hospital so there's some you
know risk associated with infection and
you know all traditional
Health practices it's it's actually a
widespread Norm there's 200 million
girls and women alive today who have
been cut in Africa Middle East and Asia
and once you have been cut there can be
serious health consequences both at the
time of cutting is as I mentioned but
even later on increased risk of STIs
difficulty of giving birth to children
so here you see a map of Africa with a
gradient in color that shows you the
prevalence of fgc among women in the age
range 15 to 49 this is data from UNICEF
and you see there are countries like
Somalia where basically the practices
Universal
even countries like Egypt have had an
extremely high rates estimated at 91
percent the other country I'll talk
about today is Sierra Leone well I won't
talk about it I will just quickly
reference it the where the practice is
at 90 percent but you can see how
there's a a very high prevalence of the
practice
across Africa
so
um you know the first question uh that
we can try and ask is
if we take a long-term view of how this
practice have evolved and what's going
to happen in the future
um what do we have to say as economists
and I I think here it's it's helpful to
understand both modeling choices that
have been used and policy approaches
in the light of what's been the common
wisdom the common wisdom is that with
something negative like fgc you go in
and you say don't do it okay so the
models are you have a choice of
choosing the detrimental action or the
other action and very often these
prescriptions even when they translate
into law are not respected so Dowry is
actually illegal but you know it's not
disappearing and similarly for if you
see many countries have legislation
against it now what I'll try to do in
this first part is to say suppose that
the goal is to get rid of these Norms in
the long run what happens if instead of
adopting a zero one perspective you
consider a setting where there are
intermediate Alternatives so something
that is still bad but a bit less bad
than the extreme okay and uh in in the
example of diary you could say instead
of outlawing diary you could put a cup
in the example of child marriage you
could say instead of saying it's age 18
let's uh you know decrease the minimum
age at marriage to say 16. what would be
the effect of something like this and
this is an interesting question because
of course there can be
implications that relate to Human Rights
and values on which I will be silent in
this lecture but taking the uh you know
kind of efficiency perspective and
saying uh what is it that's going to
make it easier to get rid of the norm in
the end there is a trade-off so on the
positive side you can think that there
are individuals who if you face them
with the choice between a traits and
nothing are still not willing to abandon
the trade so they would stick to with
the detrimental action but if you
propose a trait that is to some extent a
substitute they might take that step
and then you go one period ahead and you
say now that you are at this different
traits maybe it's easier to take an
extra step and so on and so forth and
until you eventually get rid of the
normal together and this is what we're
gonna call Stepping Stone convergence
but on the negative side
think again about having moved from the
extremely bad trade to the intermediate
one what's your incentive to abandon
that intermediate trait at that point
precisely because it's less costly you
might actually decide to stay there
forever okay we say that that becomes an
absorbing state in that case the
presence of the intermediate trait has
not helped you quite the opposite okay
so we came across these
trade-off when precisely when we were
thinking about policy work in Somalia
because as you will see
um in Somalia with the Salim and other
Cutters as you will see there are
different types of female circumcision
and in our dialogues with policy
Partners who were holding these very
dichotomic view it's bad and all forms
should be really actively discouraged we
started thinking you know would it make
it easier for us to focus on the most
extreme as opposed to the intermediate
but then we also understood well there
are risks and and we decided to try and
use some Theory to guide us in our
understanding of these trade-offs so
what this paper uh does is to think
about
social norms in a setting whereas
interdependent since and but were more
than two actions are allowed we will
study the transition Dynamics and we
derive conditions under which this type
of stepping stone convergence can occur
and then we develop an econometric
approach that allows us to test whether
these conditions hold in the data so we
collected some data uh in Somalia and
basically
try to map the model to the data to see
what can we say about what happened in
the past and about the future and uh
although as I will show you know the
Somalia case we think it's particularly
interesting there's nothing in what I
say especially on the theoretical front
that really makes this study of
transition specific to fgc so um yfgc
then as an example if you look at the
who definition there are different types
of increasing severity it's called
they're called type 1 2 and 3 and in
Somalia indeed there are even different
names for these practices types one or
two and two that are less invasive are
called Suna and type 3 that's more
invasive it's called pharonic
and so going to the model I'm gonna
um sometimes use the term Suna or
pharonic to give you um kind of a
representation of what these actions are
but just think of this uh as a model
where there's a large population of
Agents uh and they can choose between
three actions low medium and high okay
I'm gonna rank them in this way when we
think about Sunnah because what I have
in mind is the health costs of these
actions of course we can go back to this
later if you think about either a
religious component or a cultural
component it's not obvious that they
would be ordered in this direction but
then again as you will see you know the
argument for stepping stone can only
exist where there is at least some
benefit in moving from the intermediate
stage to the other state age if the
intermediate action sooner had both a
kind of a health benefit and a cultural
benefit and dominated the other two no
stepping stone transition can occur so
at any point there's a proportion of
players that choose a certain action and
what's key and this is a standard
formulation in the analysis of norms is
that your utility from a given action
will depend on the vector which includes
you know what fraction of the population
has chosen the various options and while
you do have an intrinsic utility that's
independent from what everyone everyone
else is doing there is this social
utility which is decreasing in the share
of people who choose action J different
from yours okay and how is it decreasing
well most models broken Duluth and
others use these social penalty factors
where someone who chooses J Will inflict
a cost s on you when you choose I
different from J so this s parameters
are assumed to be positive okay they are
zero for those who choose your own
action
and so uh this term is what generates
the desire for Conformity okay and then
there's a an error term that is assumed
to be extreme value distributed
so um what do we
um in you what we do we assume in the
model as I said we rank the utility and
we assume positive costs uh different
from what uh most of the literature is
doing we're not assuming symmetry so we
allow people who choose I to punish
those who choose J in a different way
from how those who choose J punish those
who choose I which if you think again of
uh examples kind of make sense because
it's not obvious that this punishment
should be symmetric this complicates the
analysis because you no longer you can
no longer use potential games and proofs
become a little bit more complex but the
the key
dynamics that we identify are actually
we are able to do it even without the
Assumption of symmetry
time is continuous people receive
revision opportunities at random
intervals and so on average you expect
to have one one revision opportunity per
unit of time and agents because of this
error term are going to choose perturbed
best responses so most of the time they
play best response but there are some
deviations and uh with the extreme value
distributed shocks it's a well-known
result that the probability of choosing
a certain action when the state is p is
given by this logic function and when
the parameter beta is the Precision of
the process so when beta is zero you're
basically choosing at random when beta
tends to one you're choosing a best
response
and in general although the Dynamics are
complex a lot of the intuition can be uh
gained by looking at the case with the
large population and with the uh you
know that approximate best responses so
I'm gonna give you the definition of
stepping stone and then the most
important part of the theoretical uh
contribution is understanding the
conditions for stepping stone and the
transition Dynamics so an action M which
remember is the intermediate one is a
stepping stone if along every Dynamic
path in the large population limit when
you start from the norm that is the
worst action uh you have that
diffraction of people choosing that
decreases over time the fraction
choosing the intermediate action first
increases and then decreases and finally
uh the fraction that choose the best
quote to quote action increases until
you basically have the majority of the
population playing the high action and
the Dynamics have this interesting
feature that there is an inflection
point so what's the inflection point is
when basically you are indifferent
between playing the intermediate and the
high utility action that's when finally
the process will make the uh kind of the
jump to the uh best uh equilibrium and
in this case we can say that if m is a
stepping stone that the transition
occurs in the following way first people
start from the bad norm and they deviate
to the intermediate one this is what
this you know smaller step is allowing
you to do at some point there's going to
be enough of a fraction of people that
are choosing the intermediate that
whoever deviates from then on can do the
big jump directly okay and that's a
function of the fact that by having
reduced the fraction of those who are
playing the very negative action the
punishments are now decreased because
the the kind of the other group is now
fragmented some play M some play yes and
so you don't get punished by a big
fraction that's playing a DL actually
okay and this is the
expression for this uh inflection point
which we denote with Q star
so if you think about the Dynamics when
you have a stepping stone what happens
is that you're starting from an
equilibrium where
um you know most of the population is is
playing the L action
um I told you in Somalia 98 of the women
are cut you will see that until more or
less the mid 90s that was actually 98
being cut with pharaonic the worst form
so we were here okay and then you see a
transition happening towards the
intermediate which is sooner okay now
this is kind of a theoretical graph I'm
not telling you that this is what the
data suggests but if in the case where
sooner we're a stepping stone we would
be seeing something where the moment you
approach Q star then the the system
moves to the best equilibrium which is
people actually playing the uncut but if
Suna becomes absorbing at that point you
go here and then you get in the Basin of
Attraction of the M norm and you're no
longer reaching the uncut unless you
were already starting quite close to
that okay
so when is it that we can expect these
virtuous process of convergence to occur
the necessary and sufficient condition
in the best response model are three uh
inequalities so the first inequality
here is the ratio of the difference in
Social sanction when starting I'm gonna
give you the sooner example starting
from pharonic qdv81 Cut minus starting
from faronic udva too soon and this is
the ratio the difference in intrinsic
utility so having a relatively large
value of this ratio means that the
social cost of switching from the say
worst action to the best one is too high
relative to the gain in intrinsic
utility that you would get so that's why
you're not doing the big jump directly
what are the other two conditions say
they
additions are saying that instead if you
compare the social sanctions foregoing
either from pharonic to sooner or from
Suna to uncut and you relate those to
the gains in intrinsic utility this time
the sanctions are relatively low okay so
that's why once you've done the first
step
this is why you can do the first step
and this is why once you've done the
first step you can then go to the uncut
equilibrium Okay so
you can rearrange these and get that a
necessary condition not sufficient but
necessary is the so-called reverse
triangle inequality which says that the
sanction for making the big step
directly is at least as large as the sum
of the two and what's very intuitive
about this condition it what's intuitive
is that it tells you that Stepping
Stones existence is related to a form of
convexity in sanctions okay so when you
get punished more harshly for you know
deviating a lot from the current state
of things it's a good idea to split it
into uh pieces because the sanctions for
each of the steps is relatively lower
okay so this is all uh quite intuitive
so let's take the case of Somalia and
let's try first of all to see
how you know these two forms of female
circumcision have evolved over time so
uh with Salim and other Cutters we
collected data in 141 communities across
Somalia sampling over 4 000 individuals
men and women that took part in
community meetings for an experiment
that I I will then describe and all
together this implies having information
on cutting for the female respondents
and for the daughters who are
approximately six thousand five hundred
dollars and what we know is what type of
cutting they have when they were cut
then we know attitudes towards cutting
as well as beliefs about Community
Support
and the first thing that to us was quite
interesting is that if you look at the
um incidence of these two types pharonic
Sunnah across subclans you see that
they're pretty much uh both present
which means that one type or the other
is not an ethnic marker okay so it's not
about identifying one subclan versus
another you see that the share uncut is
in fact extremely low in our data as
well the other thing that's interesting
if instead of subclans you calculate
these rates by community so these are
141 bars you see that with the few
exceptions that are either entirely
sooner or kind of entirely faronic by
and large you see prevalence of both
forms in each and every community and
again unfortunately not huge shares of
uncut women and girls anywhere okay so
um
descriptives the age at which girls are
cut here is around 8.5 or 9 depending on
the type and the decision to be cut when
we prompt them and say who makes this
decision and you can say more than one
person you see indeed in most cases the
mother is held responsible for that okay
in about one-third to forty percent of
the case also the father
grandmothers seem to play a lower role
of course this does not exclude the fact
that the mother might internalize the
preferences of the father so you know
I'm not making too much out of it but
it's still something that to some extent
is implemented generation after
generation with some element of decision
also by women and uh I told you you know
there are utility intrinsic utility
payoffs which can include many many
factors here's the only one type of
factors that could go in there and
that's the health cost uh but these
Health costs we find are quite
informative because when you ask female
respondents did you yourself experience
complication you see that 63 percent
almost experience complication from
pharonic uh and uh only 11 percent from
sooner if you go to the Next Generation
which is the daughters pharonic
complications are still extremely high
because this is really um you know
extremely invasive those from Suna go
down to three percent and then we have
the breakdown into what type of
complication and you can see a very
similar pattern where from pharonic you
have all sorts of negative Health
complications but with Sunnah it's quite
low okay and I want you to keep this in
mind because
you will see what conclusions we reach
about the stepping stone but intuitively
if you are expecting people to have
incentives to abandon the practice for
example because it's very costly in
terms of health this doesn't seem to be
in place from their understanding or
their experience okay
so um let's try and use the model to
um shed light on what the transition
process looks like so we need to map
into the model we need approximations
for the stock and the flow okay and
what we're gonna do in the analysis that
I show you is to say Remember The
Cutting Edge around nine I'm gonna say
that if you are 10 or more and you have
a certain trait you enter that stock
okay if you are 10 or more and you're
still uncut but when we prompt your
parents you say okay your daughter is
uncut what are you planning to do and
they have an option of say you know cut
her with this type of circumcision or
leave her uncut if they say that you're
gonna be cut it's just a matter of time
and they give the type of circumcision
we actually attribute that girl to the
stock big because in our model you get
to choose ones okay so we are trying to
map this to the model and this also
helps because at that point if you are
uncut there's no single point in time
where we could pinpoint that you would
be uncut and this way everybody it gets
10 gets assigned to whatever the final
action will be but in the paper we do um
we use other forms of computing stocks
and flows and those are similar so the
stock is going to be basically the
cumulative proportions uh for the
cohorts we have and the flow is in any
year you know how many girls are cut
with a certain uh type of cut okay and
we use three-year moving average to get
rid of some of the noise and you know
these results are robust to instead of
10 using cutoffs of 9 10 or 12. so here
is the evolution of the flow
from the early 70s until when we
collected the data okay so the blue line
is giving you the flow of faroni cuts so
that means that the women who were cut
in these decades were pretty much always
cut pharonic okay there's a slow
increase in the share sooner until the
early to mid 90s where you see that
suddenly things start speeding up and
then there's a
Sunnah is now the prevalent form of Kati
okay everybody pretty much most of the
people who get cut today are cut with
Sunnah there are still some girls cut
with pharonic you see uncut is quite
stable and low there's this little blip
here but really almost unnoticeable so
if you think about Norm's transition we
find this to be a pretty striking graph
because it really shows why nor being
displaced by another of course when you
do the stocks because there's you know
the early flows contribute to
generating a cumulative share of ironic
that stays High uh of course you know
the crossing occurs a bit later but this
already these days the stock of Sunnah
is now higher than that of ironic okay
so how can we explain that blip so if
you think of the model what the model is
saying is that you're starting from a
bad place PL that's where we were with a
lot of ironic and then you're gonna have
some of these uh error that you know
generate some people choosing sooner uh
as that share grows at some point it
reaches a um tilt tilting Point okay so
basically the model could endogenously
generate the type of transition if you
through the increasing accumulation of
Sunnah if you read uh historical
accounts of what happened in Somalia
it's also true that since the mid-80s
human rights organization were very
vocal especially against ironic
circumcision and eventually religious
leaders decided to distance themselves
from pharonic and started emphasizes
that this was not a required environment
of Islam so you can also think of this
as kind of reinforcing the potential
dynamics of the model y because you can
think that you know the fact that the
imams were now endorsing sooner relative
to pharonic is gonna reduce the
sanctions for going from farana to
Sunnah also you know it's going to
increase the benefits of Sunnah if you
are a religious person and at the same
time all of these campaigns against
faronic decrease the relative utility of
pharaonic so all of these kind of can
help us look at what happened in the
past
make sense of it but of course the
question we have now is uh given that
everybody is cutting Sunnah is this just
the first stage of a transition out of
uh fgc completely or not and here
ideally you would want to have estimates
of those U and S parameters which are
quite difficult to have and we try to
have some survey based proxies which we
include in the paper to corroborate the
other approach but today I will not show
you those results but what's interesting
is that in the absence of those
parameters estimates you can still use
some of the properties implied by the
model
and the estimates of stocks and flows
and that's enough to predict what's
going to happen Okay so I'm gonna show
you three tests that can be used in
general uh not just for this uh fgc
approach to understand if a certain uh
action can be a stepping stone so the
first comes from the reverse triangle
inequality remember we said that's a
necessary condition and uh with this
logic specification that we have you can
express the log ratio of the flows as a
function of utility and then the
different stocks
and basically if you write it for the
share the flow of uncut over Sunnah
you find sorry this is a p that's
missing you find that the coefficient on
the stockofaronic is actually given by a
positive constant in the model
multiplied by this okay what is this
expression it's basically the reverse
triangle inequality because remember
that inequality was saying that slh
needs to be at least as large as the sum
of these two so how can you test whether
the necessary condition for stepping
stone is met you can run a regression of
these log ratio of the flows on the two
stocks pH and pl and just look at
whether the coefficient on PL is
negative or not okay
and when you run that regression you
actually find a positive not a negative
coefficient which is the first way of
saying the necessary condition for
stepping stone does not hold in the data
so this is test number one
it's nice it does rely on the fact that
this specific functional form comes from
the logit formulation
second test is what we call equal flow
test this one does not rely on the logit
formulation what is an equal flow
remember the inflection point that says
that at some point you're gonna have
that the utility from the two choices uh
is equal if you are on your path to a
transition in particular you can
derive the condition that if at some
point you have a decreasing share of say
faronic and the stock of uncut is at
least as large as that of Sunnah from
that point on the system is predicted to
converge to uncut okay so this is what
would be happening your this is the
equal flow means that at some point the
flow of the two is equal and from that
point you definitely go to one cut so
what have we done we have computed these
sigmas flow into uncut and flow into to
Sunnah for every year in our data and
sorry it's Let Me skip this and we have
plotted you know the frequency of how
many times was this ratio of Sigma H to
Sigma n 0
0.50.1 I mean approximated in bins
remember if you say equal flow and then
you're off it means that the ratio
should be 0.5 or larger and you see that
in in our data this ratio is always to
the left okay so it's a sufficient not a
necessary condition but we haven't
reached that sufficient condition in the
data that we have so far so that's a
further confirmation that you know test
one and test two don't tell us that we
are on our path out of Sunnah the last
test that we do is to basically simulate
the model so what we're doing is we are
estimating the dynamic implied Dynamics
and again given our model we don't need
to estimate all the parameters it's
enough to estimate these log odds ratios
as a function of the stocks and because
you know they sum the flow sumatuan
basically through this we can infer the
mapping Sigma of P so when you simulate
the model
this is the part for which we actually
have the data okay this is what's been
happening so far starting from pharonic
the share of faroni goes down the share
of Sunnah goes up you remember that
tankat was staying very close to zero
this is what we're getting from the
model simulation okay and this dotted
part is the extrapolation to Future
years and it's kind of unequivocally
telling us that we're gonna end up with
Suna being absorbing okay so that's the
third piece of evidence
um
is this uh it's it's not super uplifting
as a conclusion the truth is that we
still have relatively few years in which
the stock of the flow into uncut has
been significant enough and it's
possible that if something changed so
for example here we're simulating an
exogenous shift uh that increases by
five percent how many people are
choosing on cutover sooner actually with
those with that kind size of a shift the
simulation predicts that you could get
out so uh I think there's some room for
saying that maybe with more years of
data and if something happened that kind
of increased this talk of ankata aside
from the model Dynamics per se we could
get out of it okay now I want to use
um so to sum up the if you think of this
framework you could try to facilitate
the transition by playing with those
parameters that govern the inequality so
you could try to have sanctions being
reduced or you know increase knowledge
about the benefits the relative benefits
or you know what kind of identity
payoffs people attach to this
I want to just emphasize that while I've
discussed everything in terms of this
fgc example there are both historical
and contemporary
examples of norms where these
intermediate action can actually be
pretty
um
meaningful one historical example that
my
quarters are very fond of is dueling and
in Europe dueling persisted for quite a
long time and it persisted longer in
France than in in England and one of the
reasons is apparently that they accepted
a less lethal form of uh weapon which is
like the intermediate action becoming
absorbing in a sense if we think at more
uh kind of recent technological
innovation let's think of smoking and
the introduction of electronic
cigarettes this could be a way to help
smokers quit or because the damage is
less with e-cigarettes than with regular
cigarettes it might actually lead people
not to quit smoking altogether so I'm
told I have 10 minutes which doesn't
leave me too much to talk about policies
to to change fgc but I'll try to give
you a flavors at least so
um if you now think of let me
take the you know where the Hat of a
policy maker be it a government an NGO
who wants to help this transition out of
a harmful Norm what can I do well one
thing is that maybe I don't trust people
to have all the information they need to
assess these intrinsic utility so I
could do information campaigns maybe
there's something that people attach to
these practices that defines how they
see themselves and identity component
and here you could think does the
identity value really depend on the
harmful side of the practice or not and
then there are potential explanations
that have more to do with the the part
of the norm that's about the expectation
so for example maybe people really think
that everybody is in favor of cutting
but in private they are not necessarily
and that's a form of pluralistic
ignorance in that case what you want to
do is realign people's beliefs or maybe
everybody has the exact uh you know
rational beliefs that they should have
simply nobody wants to move first okay
so there's a simple coordination failure
and in that case can you use
coordination tools and some ngos for
example tostan have used this public
declarations when you talk about fgc you
know working with villages to have a
critical mass of families who pledge not
to cut their daughters or not to marry
their sons to cut daughters so uh
tomorrow Lucia will present some work
that we've done in Sierra Leone where uh
fgc is actually part of an initiation
ritual that's called Bondo this is a
group uh ceremony that stretches over
one month in the sense that the girls go
together in the bush they are taught how
to become mothers wives they really
create a mutual network of support and
at the conclusion of this month The
Cutting ritual is done and we've worked
with the local NGO to test the
effectiveness of two potential
interventions one is information about
the health costs of fgc and the other is
actually to try and uh you know discuss
with communities the possibility of
using a a ritual or you know choosing a
ritual that includes everything else
that's there but replaces the cutting
with an alternative sign so preserving
in some way the symbolic value of the
practice and if you want to know what
happens show up tomorrow
now what I want to instead maybe say a
little bit more about is another
intervention that we did with the subset
of the quarters of the Somalia
transitions paper and this is about
beliefs and coordination so here we're
gonna tackle this idea that maybe people
are privately against fgc but you know
they misperceive other people's support
for it or there is this coordination
failure so what we've done there is to
hold Community meetings where sorry We
Gather people
um in a group uh
of about 30 participants in rural
Villages and they were given a secret
ballot where they could say yes or no if
they wanted to abolish faronic
circumcision so there there was no way
to identify who was Voting in a certain
way and once they cast their vote we
incentivize everybody to guess what the
share the number of people in support of
abandoning pharonic circumcision would
it be okay then in some of the
communities we end the meeting in these
communities what we will have is the
private support for the practice and the
beliefs about the community level
support
in one group of communities we opened
The Ballot Box and we say here is how
many actually voted in favor of
abandoning so this is the case where you
are correcting if there are
misperceptions you are realigning
beliefs with the actual preferences
and then we thought you know it's
important to think that aside from the
beliefs part there might be this uh
coordination uh problems so we try to
design the lab in the field equivalent
of this public declarations in some
communities uh the people who was
running the meeting drew a circle on the
floor and said if you are in favor of
abolishing pharonic circumcision you can
step into the circle so this is going to
be our coordination treatment and then
there's a third group of communities
where we first reveal the sharing
support and then we ask who wants to
step into the circle okay we have three
rounds of data collection from 2018 to
21 and there's data on traditional
circumcisors that we also have and I
will not discuss now so first I I'll
just show you this graph which has
evidence that there is indeed a
significant extent of misperception why
because
here you have the share of people who
support the abandonment of farionic vote
you know from zero to one hundred
percent of the meeting participants and
the green dashed line is the actual vote
Anonymous vote so we have no reason to
think that they lied uh this is telling
us that you know in the vast majority of
communities the share is greater than 60
with the very large fraction where it's
it's almost close to a hundred percent
but the respondents prior about how many
are in favor of abandoning is shifted to
the left which means that they actually
expect less support than there is in
practice okay so this uh opens uh the
possibility for correcting these
misperceptive beliefs and similarly if
you think about coordinator this is the
same thing which is
um the guess about those who are uh in
in favor of abandoning so this is the
belief and these are the number of
people who ended up entering the circle
okay so this exercise LED more people to
step into the circle than what they
expected to be the public support for
the practice
and I'll skip this one and just go
quickly to the result because I'm almost
out of time so first of all we go there
this is the end line data so it's two
years after the intervention and this is
the share of
um girls who've been far only cut okay
so you know the mean the Baseline sorry
the meaning the control group is quite
low because I already told you that
nowadays most people cut Sunnah you
could say why did you do the experiment
on pharonic and and not on sooner then
because in our pilot we understood that
the support for Sunnah was quite high so
if you do one of these open the ballot
experiments and then you say you know 95
percent of the people are supporting
Suna you're not gonna have much of a
decrease in
cutting rates and at the same time we
also did feel that given how much more
harmful these practices even going from
four percent to a lower number uh was an
important goal and in fact we managed to
reduce it by 1.6 percentage points now
what we were not sure would happen and
happened or you know could have happened
or not and is that happened was that in
this span of two years the rate of Suna
Cuts actually went up and the rate the
share of girls who was uncut went down
okay so in the having seen that model
with the intermediate action this is not
so surprising because something that can
happen is that in fact you go you go
away from pharonic you make the step to
Sunnah and now that Sunnah becomes more
appealing there might be some people who
from up uncut
are induced to actually choose the
Sunnah so this would not be a very
desirable outcome however it's also true
that these two years after the
intervention is not giving you the
steady state because girls get cut in a
certain age interval so if we want to
know what this does to parents
preferences and to parents choices for
all the girls that they have including
those who are too young to be cut we
should factor in the preferences uh
about uncut girls okay so in this table
you have the old result probability of
being uncut goes down but then we look
at whether for those uncut the parents
say that they are planned to be cut in
the future or planned not to be cut okay
and what's happening is that these
number must a reduction in those who are
planned to be cut in the future and an
increase in those who for the future are
planned not to be cut and indeed
if you look at the age of cutting it it
goes down a little bit and sorry I
didn't say it before but everything we
have in terms of results is pretty much
driven by the misperceptions
intervention it turns out that our
coordination device didn't work
as well and so in fact the age of
cutting went down a little bit which
means that that increases Sunnah that we
saw is probably you know some girls
whose card wasn't dissipated it was done
as sooner and then if we take the
long-term perspective and say now let's
take everybody and if you are far only
cut now or plan to be we give you a one
Suna cutter plan to be an uncut and plan
to stay uncut if you take all of this uh
the end point seems to be that there's
actually an increase in the share that
in the long term is gonna be uncut of
course course with these plants we could
say maybe it's cheap talk we don't know
what the parents are gonna do in the end
so the only thing we can do here is uh
because we had the midline and the end
line we compared the plants that they
gave us at midline with the action that
they declare it end line in the age
range in which the girls are most at
risk and we have
532 girls of which uh basically 39 have
been cut when the parents at midline had
said she's gonna stay uncut okay so we
have a seven percent deviation from
intentions which uh again
um you know eventually
doesn't seem a huge hugely important
problem but it's also true that
this is this is all we have in terms of
the data so I'll skip the additional
results and just
I think just say that in the context
that we've studied pluralistic ignorance
seem to seems to play a role and so in
that case a simple intervention based on
correcting misplaced beliefs is a viable
the coordination exercise seemed less
effective and that you know disregarding
this role of intermediate roles is
actually a limitation because we saw
that in the short run at least some of
what happens was an increase
of the intermediate form so there's
something that I have completely left
out of this discussion and we had a very
interesting for me conversation with
rohini hamsem today which is actually
the role of the law and of the
institutions because
all I've tried to discuss is still
informally enforced it's still a way of
having the kind of the social Norm
aspect not sanctioned by an authority an
illegal Authority I I think it's very
important to also pay attention to how
um you know
legal
and institutional uh
solutions to Norms change can be
implemented when they are successful or
not and also I think a long-standing
question is
eventually you want people to own these
changes this means that there are
attitudes towards harmful Norms need to
change so what comes first do you know
will my attitudes change because I see a
different Behavior or is a different
Behavior generated by attitudinal change
and I haven't found a way of solving
these obvious endogenative problem but
for me given these type of questions
it's an obvious important future
Avenue for more work so thank you for
your patience with me going slightly
over time
[Applause]
um
thank you thank you very much Eliana for
visiting us
um
oh
um so I I wanted to just connect the
three parts of your presentation I
really like the experiment you just
described in Sierra Leone which is you
know beliefs about what other people
my beliefs about Somalia oh sorry that
was Somalia okay yeah Sierra Leone is
the tomorrow okay correct
okay I like it even better
so that's about Norms you know my
beliefs about what other people think I
should be doing right now when but in
the middle part when we were talking
about this aggregate data and seeing
movements from frionic to Sunnah right I
mean we have these standard problems
with those aggregate data that's just
about correlated and observables right
like as you said it could just be
religious edict that matters so that all
of that could just be signaling that
what we should be focusing on is
religious edicts or changing the law or
something like that right and that's why
in like in the labor literature you know
this what how you define or how
Christina Baker use a defined Norms it
sounded like like a strategic
complementarity right my decision to
adopt depends on what other people are
doing and they're you know in the peer
effect literature in labor we know that
we have to be very careful like the mass
and Moretti type approach on right so so
I just worry I mean I I like the the
belief part but I just worry that if
you're not careful about how we use the
word Norms maybe we would be
misattributing a lot the importance of
Law changes to focusing too much on
Norms yeah so uh thank you and this
helps me clarify something which I hope
I didn't use causal language when I was
describing that middle part if I did
um absolutely not intended but so the
way I presented the the transition or
the flow it's basically
indistinguishable for us whether it was
governed by the Dynamics by the
religious leaders action we're not
um you know we're not making much out of
that we're just saying this is a context
where the three actions make sense if
you take historical data you see the
switch that's it what we're trying to
use the model for is to say with
aggregate data
what should you see as a precondition
for this now getting you out of so now
together and uh we're just showing that
we're not seeing that so it's more like
saying on the basis of what the model
predicts
um the uh just the evolution of those
stocks and flows is not consistent with
the second step of the transition we're
not saying that you know if the
religious leaders intervene now sooner
would would no longer be absorbing so
all of this is for us I think a way of
asking can you use this
um
these analytical framework where there
is interdependency and where you're just
trying to understand am I in a situation
where there is a form of convexity that
would generate these uh pattern of
stocks and flows or not and purely
descriptively you're saying this doesn't
match it but we know that we cannot
attribute you know a cause and effect
especially to the first part of data
because we know there have been also
Evolutions in the institutional
framework that we're not modeling let me
also say why we decided not to take a
path where we start modeling incentives
of religious leaders and so on we were
trying to see this as really as
applicable as possible to many different
types of norms and the moment we get
more serious and more realistic about
the Somali uh
institutional setting will lose the
ability to use the same model for
e-cigarettes for example so this comes
at a cost we know there are some
interesting feature of what happened
there that we're not capturing but I
think it's still instructive to show
that even with these extremely stylized
framework we are able to to say
something about what comes next
if the parameters stay constant so
that's another big thing I don't know if
that was the next question by someone
but of course those conditions and
everything says that the S's and they
use for the coming years to which we
extrapolate are the ones for the past
year big assumption
oh
so one type of policy intervention you
didn't spend much time on is strong
paternalistic interventions and and here
I'm thinking of smoking
so in your model that this utility the
cost of all these practices is extremely
high I don't think anyone any woman or
any girl would claim that they enjoyed
the practice
as opposed to smoking where most smokers
actually love to smoke and so the cost
there was low and yet I think somehow we
managed at least in the U.S to move from
an equilibrium where everyone smokes the
one where at least within the educated
class most people don't smoke
and the only explanation the only polish
intervention I can think of was very
strong paternalism
[Music]
so I'm wondering if why you haven't you
know been
more pushy on that front
um
I think we were
so that if you think of this
paternalism it is not obvious that the
appeal of the intermediate Norm at that
point becomes um
so crucial you might as well try and be
paternalistic towards the most desirable
state so we had this idea of thinking
about step step wise processes
I also don't know in the smoking case I
do agree there was an important role
played by paternalism
you know I like to think about
um you know things like television or
you know and in my view what happened
with smoking was also that it started
being considered less cool
so in terms of how young people for
example choose whether to smoke or not I
think the image around who is a smoker
um kind of changed over the years and
now it's very interesting smokers
disappeared from movies and now they're
back and uh so I do think and I'm not
able to quantify in any way you know
this is super
not grounded in any serious research
that I've done and maybe there is that I
can look at but to me it was a
combination of a paternalistic
interventions having you know certain
pictures on the packs of cigarettes and
all of that but also how Society started
portraying and viewing smokers no longer
so desirable
and
and then I think nowadays strong
lobbying to to have it back in some form
of a desirable
practice but so I yeah maybe I I didn't
think I had so much to say about
paternalistic approaches which doesn't
mean that they're not important similar
to the law and the issue of institutions
to follow up on this question
I will maybe frame it a bit differently
by talking about not personality
approach but top down
like for instance you have a powerful
Imam
that changed his mind
or you manage to negotiate with Imam and
said
why don't you pretend that we are doing
this
you know
we pay you this
and then you tell everyone else that we
we are not going to do this anymore
you know I think in in West Africa
particularly in Benin for instance I've
known a lot of instances where
um
you know you it you you are not I mean
like we want to stop let's say physical
punishment
uh for some misbehavior and the way to
do it is
you pretend
you know that this is what you are
punishing the person physically but then
you don't
you know it is as if there is
it becomes just
like uh you know a ritual you know
so that you do it but and then you are
not doing it because you minimize you
know you know so so so
in this context for instance did you did
you have to deal with some uh kind of
local leaders and
try to leverage their influence
to rethink the whole the whole practice
a little bit you know have you have you
run into this so it's
an point the in the Somali context we of
course had to get permission to go in
the communities hold the meetings there
was no point of negotiation or conflict
of interest because given that we were
not discussing sooner but we were only
talking about faronik there is a full
alignment and there are parts of Somalia
where imams have even issued fatwas
against pharaonic in puntland for
example in 2018 so in that respect
we we were not in a position where we
said let's try together to get out of
the practice that you are actually you
know most associated with which is what
the Sunnah is we did collect the data on
circumcisors because we also wanted to
understand the incentives of the ones
who practice it and you might think that
in addition to having you know the
imam's
sanctioning different ways of
Performing the ritual or abandoning it
you would also need the compliance by
the circumcisors and so that part to us
is interesting to study I cannot speak
for Celine but if I were to to say
what do you think is gonna work do you
feel that everything you've tried is you
know that's it I wouldn't say so I would
think that involving the local leaders
is probably something that's first order
importance it's not it's something that
maybe
requires a lot more
embeddedness in the local context
Somalia is a very difficult context for
us to work in as Outsiders and so but I
I do agree with you that it might be you
know the most promising strategy on
paper in West Africa it was a bit
different because we were very careful
with Lucia to try and avoid as much as
possible this top down
approach because in fact
you know the the local understanding of
Bondo or fgc is a lot less negative than
what we portrayed and the interaction
with the communities were handled by
this NGO and this is a
um it's called Amazonian initiative
movement it's actually for many years
they've been acting off the ground and
what they do is they try and because
it's a secret society I think they try
and say you choose the sign you choose
what you want to do but they try and
just
um
remove the association of all the good
things are bonded with the cutting again
what could there be in terms of
institutional Partnerships in that case
we think it's slightly more complicated
the government hasn't shown a
determination to go against Bondo in
summer in Sierra Leone so far I would
love to hear more about Benin because
that's one context where we haven't
worked thank you okay I also have a
question so talking a little bit about
the law and the institutional setting so
in Somalia you didn't say if it was
illegal to start with so I don't think
it is illegal the Sunnah but the so The
Chronic has been with the
so then the question is a little bit on
this top down or this legal settings
it's who are you punishing or who are
you who is the law against is it against
the mother is it against the doctor
who's doing it uh and how can you
institutionalize and monitor that it
happens it's not easy at all because uh
except I mean the Sierra Leone is a case
where monitoring is super easy because
it's a group and you know if you know a
bunch of girls are gone for a month in
many other cat settings it's done
um you know at home it's a very private
act
the only case I'm familiar with
I mentioned it today in our discussion
is that of Burkina Faso Burkina also has
you know a practice of fgc but in recent
years the government has become its
banned and the government has this
decided to enforce the law so luche and
I initially
um
thought about
doing
an intervention in Burkina and we
started some you know focus group and
pilot work and it became clear to us
that
people didn't want to talk about it they
were extremely reluctant to discuss if
you see they said there's no fgc in our
communities and we later learned that
there had been trials
that had been brought to the rural areas
so instead of uh so both the family and
the circumcisors were punished and
instead of holding them in the capital
they were on purpose held in locations
where the population would become aware
and this apparently said at least in
terms of willingness to discuss it or to
report it had an effect I don't know if
it had an effect on cutting rates but
and we haven't gone you know back to
study why they became serious about
enforcing how they did it we we read
about these trials but I do think that
is
you know it's one instance where
finding out about it would probably come
from some monitoring of the circumcisors
and then
probably that's how they do it
thanks for the really interesting
presentation
um in your model one thing I was
interested in was the fact that the
reference group is kind of exogenously
given and I know this is outside the
scope of what you talked about but maybe
if you had some speculative thoughts
about you know what happens when
reference groups come into contact with
each other or are there cases where some
subgroup might decide to split off and
and kind of divorce itself from the
broader reference group to protect a
norm
I that's a great question in fact you
know
almost by definition if you wanted to
split the population into now my
reference group are the people who are
choosing my action I pay no cost you
know I'm always free to deviate so I
think
the problem is interesting to the extent
that you cannot fully redefine the
reference group in a way to align it to
your own preferences now is there a
feasible way from an analytical
perspective to to study
um you know in an intermediate version
that's not the full population Health
constant as I did not the extreme in
which my reference group is always
whoever thinks about like me but there's
um you know a partition that's different
I'll be honest I haven't seen anything
like this at least in the social norms
literature of course people working on
coalitions might might have tools that
come in handy and I I don't know whether
any of what we've done would generalize
to to that setting in principle it
should make it easier to transition on
because you're always decreasing the
punishment if you strategically redefine
your reference group but you know there
are if these references groups are there
because they also provide
they have a function
you want to have a large enough group
that you can do risk sharing with or so
so there are economies of scale to some
extent in keeping these groups not as
small as it renders cost less this
particular action choice but
analytically I haven't seen anything
going in that direction I agree it seems
a very very interesting question
I think we can take one more question
thank you very much for the fascinating
presentation
um I had a question on sort of the risks
of a non-reversal uh particularly within
communities where there's sort of an
embracing of traditional ideas do we see
cases where like over Generations is a
re-adoption of harmful Norms uh for
example in cases where grandmothers or
mothers are uncut or undergo sort of
Sunnah but then their children undergo
veronic cases
uh so we haven't seen that reversal in
the data in fact the kind of the uh the
trend uh is uh always for me in our data
mothers may be having faronic and
daughter sooner and never we never see
uh the opposite in the data I do think
that in theory you could actually
um have that case uh where there's some
backlash again maybe coming out of our
framework in our framework because of
that ranking of utilities by definition
if you manage to overcome the social
sanctions and you go to a point where
the intrinsic utility is higher there's
no reason to move from there so you
would need some extraneous element to
the theory I presented which empirically
I think could happen in cases with the
back backlash but
thank you Eliana for a great talk and
I'd invite everyone to join us now for
reception which I think is in the new
economics building so thank you very
much
[Music]
thank you